i mean in the beginning i just
tried to talk myself out of starting
this business because
it really didn't make sense in in that
time
of the world but the more i looked into
climate change the more i understood
what a humongous problem it is gonna be
and i just i just had no choice
about two years ago nobody was really
interested they didn't think that it
would be
a good business they didn't really see
the money in it
that's all changed so rapidly everybody
and their grandma is calling themselves
a climate investor now which is
fantastic
i'm henrietta moon i'm the ceo and
co-founder of carboculture
and carboculture is removing atmospheric
carbon
by turning biomass waste into highly
stable carbon that remains stable for
1000 years
most life on earth is carbon and it's
our fourth most abundant element
so so it's not bad per se we just have
it in the wrong place
in too much scale so we need to think of
the most elegant way to actually
bring down that carbon from the
atmosphere and put it to use somewhere
where we can
use it better this challenge is at the
core
of carboculture's mission the helsinki
based startup is focused on solving the
earth's carbon problem
while offering a viable business model
one that didn't even exist
at the beginning of her career i ended
up in this crazy program that was
three month intense program at nasa ames
in california and that's where i met
my co-founder chris karstens back then
there was no price on carbon
emission trading was at maybe five euros
a ton and
nobody was really interested in pursuing
that as a business model
we got started properly in 2017. today
the carbon market is trading at
over 10 times that so times have changed
henrietta and her team turned to nature
itself for inspiration
on how to make this model both effective
and profitable
every year nature draws down carbon in
the form of
photosynthesis into all our biomass
trees and plantations and crops and
everything you see
but naturally when that biomass like the
trees die
they decompose and re-enter the
atmosphere again and that's the natural
carbon cycle
at carboculture we were trying to figure
out what is the most elegant way to
actually draw down some of this carbon
and instead of trying to invent machines
to take out parts per million from the
atmosphere
we decided that millions of years of
nature already knows how to do it
so if you see a forest today and in 500
years
it'll essentially be the same size it's
not going to 10x
its carbon removal capacity or or grow
10 times
larger so we have these solar powered
allies
who use photosynthesis and turn this
carbon from the atmosphere into biomass
and we take that biomass such as
nutshells or peach pits or
or tree waste and we put it into our
patented reactor and we
rapidly take it to ultra high heat where
it carbonizes
it doesn't decompose it's not eaten by
microbes or anything
and and we can store it safely in the
soil by doing this the
carbon that's almost pure carbon remains
stable from 1 000 years to let's say
maybe up to a million years
[Music]
their first facility resides in
california which operates
as a proof of concept to demonstrate the
process
basically we put biomass in there and
and we put them inside we take them to
ultra high temperature about a thousand
degrees celsius for a split
second and in that time the biomass
carbonizes
so it turns into a charcoal like form
you can
mix it into compost or put it in the
soil or use it for water filtration or
just
bury it in the ground in an old mine
shaft or something
[Music]
our technology is like on a basic level
the same thing
as turning wood into a carbon is is
something that everybody can do in their
home fireplace right
but now if you want to make it like
ultra ultra ultra efficient
and actually store the carbon away now
it gets a little bit more difficult
but the kind of principle is the same
right now our batch takes about two
hours
for half a ton so we can do about 500
pounds per hour
let's say of biomass now that they've
mastered the concept
it's really just a matter of scaling it
up by a factor of
a million or so if we put a million of
these systems around the world we can
actually use part of the energy in the
biomass itself
to power these systems and in this way
we're helping the green transition
of the grid instead of hindering it this
next scale up at scale would remove
about
13 000 tons of carbon dioxide annually
so so make a few thousand tons of
biocarbon and
that's a big step for us though
carboculture has recently raised 6.2
million dollars in seed financing
it will take a lot more funding to get
carboculture's vision to scale
this herculean effort will require
investments from both public
and private sectors and now that carbon
capture programs like this
are beginning to get traction henrietta
welcomes the competition
if we look at the big picture we have a
north star
mission of a gigaton of removal which is
one billion tons
and it's a real insanity target it's
definitely not easy
it's light years away from where we are
today but for us it means that we also
need to get to that kind of
scale and there's probably going to be
10 to 100 companies like
us in maybe a decade from now that will
be
trying to get to that gargantuan scale
that is needed